again the democrats are trying to force
through the notion that this is
everything that they are doing is is
required because if not the world will
burn and this is why they're focusing in
on climate change everything's a crisis
because whenever you can declare a
crisis this means that you can take
absolute control so over the last year
and a half we had an actual crisis in
the form of a global pandemic that's
killed millions of people but nobody i
mean but nobody actually thinks that
climate change over the course of the
next century is a crisis it may be a
problem it might be a serious problem
that we need to deal with no one thinks
it's a crisis that requires us to dump
out trillions of dollars from a piggy
bank that does not exist into an economy
that's already overheated nobody thinks
that but democrats have to ratchet up
the rhetoric so you get a piece like
this from the new york times today when
the world is on the brink 3.5 trillion
dollars is a pittance a pittance by
abram lustgarten environmental reporter
for propublica wildlife organization
there will be no bargains with an
overheating climate the 3.5 trillion
dollar price tag that president biden
proposed for his climate-heavy buildback
battery act might seem enormous but over
the long term it will be a pittance what
we don't spend now will cost us much
more later the bills for natural
disasters and droughts and power outages
are already pouring in within a few
decades the total bill will be
astronomical as energy debts surge
global migration swells industrial
upheaval follows the scale of the threat
demands a new way of thinking about
spending past budgets can no longer
guide how governments spend money in the
future some economists and climate
scientists have calculated climate
change could cost the united states the
equivalent of nearly fourth of nearly
four percent of its gross domestic
product a year by 2100
four percent is likely a conservative
estimate that comes out to about 840
billion dollars per year four percent of
the american gdp it figured on last
year's economy okay well um
let's say that that's true four percent
of the american gdp that's 840 billion
dollars a year i noticed that you guys
are attempting to spend like a multiple
of that
i noticed that that we are going to have
a four trillion dollar budget
that we are going to have dumped out 1.9
trillion earlier this year that we spent
seven trillion dollars last year i've
noticed that um
and so your notion is we should spend
much more money than it's going to cost
us
again the all of this neglects the fact
that there is going to be future
economic growth and if you crimp the
plan right if you crimp economic growth
with regulation and taxation what you
end up doing is lowering the growth
curve so if you say four percent of
annual gdp you have to estimate how much
the annual gdp is going to be if the
original curve is going to be high and
now you've lowered the curve okay that
curve lowering itself is a major cost
this is something that bjorn lomberg is
constantly pointing out over at the wall
street journal
he says the adaptation doesn't make the
cost of global warming go away entirely
but it does reduce it dramatically
higher temperatures will shrink harvest
if farmers keep growing the same crop
but they're likely to adapt corn
production in north america shifted away
from the southeast and toward the upper
midwest when sea levels rise governments
build defenses like levees flood walls
and drainage systems that protected new
orleans for much of hurricane ida's
ferocity this year
nonetheless many in the media push
unrealistic projections of climate
catastrophes while ignoring adaptation
this is correct of course
you can see how far from reality these
sorts of projections are in one heavily
cited study depicted in a graph if you
assume no society will adapt to any sea
level rise between now and 2100 you'll
find that vast areas of the world will
be routinely flooded causing 55 trillion
dollars in damage annually in 2100 or
about 5 of global gdp
but as the study emphasizes in reality
societies are likely to adapt
by raising the height of dykes the study
shows humanity can negate almost all of
that only 15 000 people would be flooded
every year which is a remarkable
improvement compared with the 3.4
million people flooded in 2000
the total cost of damage investments in
new dikes and maintenance costs of
existing dikes will fall six-fold
between now and 2100 to .008 percent of
world's gdp so in other words you can do
something about climate change but it
does not require this garbage so what is
this really about what this is really
about is making people dependent on the
government so the white house put
forward
another one of these absurd i mean it's
just absurd slide shows now you remember
back in 2012 barack obama was pushing
very hard on spending on social policy
and he put out something called the life
of julia and the life of julia was
roundly mocked because it showed julia
as this woman who was utterly dependent
on government her entire life and it was
openly mocked it was mocked on late
night tv
it was mocked by everybody on the right
most people in the center thought it was
stupid now the biden administration is
bringing it back like i don't know who
there was like life of julia was great
now we need a sequel life of linda so
this is what they did they put together
something called life of linda and i
gotta tell you linda leads a pretty sad
life
linda's life according to this is really
pathetic
number one
linda is pregnant and there's no father
anywhere in the picture
always always and forever the government
is dead the government is dead this is
the goal right welfare policy it's a
substitute for father
okay so here is the life of linda as
presented by the biden white house right
you're supposed to be optimistic about
this and excited about this this is what
you can hope for from life linda is a
working mother in peoria illinois she
works at a local manufacturing facility
as a production worker and earns forty
thousand dollars per year she is
pregnant with her son leo
okay so this is i i i love how they have
to just violate all the stop the gender
stereotyping she's a production worker
with a hard hat and
she's not a teacher or something right
okay so we'll start with that they're of
course they're women in manufacturing
i'm just saying that heavy manufacturing
is is stereotypically a male industry
and they know that which is why they did
this
once leo is born father nowhere in the
picture by the way linda begins
receiving child tax credits of 300 per
month 3 600 annually to help cover
essential costs like groceries rent
medicine i have a question uh how much
is that going to help if the inflation
outpaces the child tax credit also
if she does not have to work in order to
receive the child tax credit how's that
going to impact the hours that she takes
on at the manufacturing facility is she
just going to stay out of the workforce
considering there are a bevy of other
benefits available to linda
but don't worry the government will step
in regardless
as leo grows up says the white house the
government helps cover the cost for his
daycare guaranteeing that linda doesn't
need to pay more than seven percent of
her income on child care well that's
exciting so we are going to also make
sure that leo can grow up in a
government facility right because again
linda's not married so there are no
options for linda to stay home
with the kid
so that's great when leo turns three he
attends a high quality pre-k program for
free
um i have my doubts
i have my doubts we were told that the
public schools were going to be a high
quality program for free
nope
america's public schools are a giant
fail the only public schools that are
good are the ones that are locally
driven by excellent parents
that's that's the big defining factor
pre-k universal pre-k has been a giant
fail
okay the the head start program which
this is modeled on
has poor outcomes
and they're pretty clear about this
being modeled on head start
the head start program according to the
heritage foundation was launched in 1965
enrolling 560 000 kids in the new
federally funded 8 week summer program
at the time proponents were clear that
headstart's sole purpose was to prepare
children for elementary school
unfortunately more than half a century
later it sucks the department of health
and human services which administers
head start revealed in december 2012
2012 that the nearly 8 billion head
start program has little to no impact on
the cognitive social emotional or health
outcomes of participants or the
parenting skills of their parents in
fact participation in head start
actually had some negative effects on
enrolled children federal researchers
reported worse peer relations and lower
teacher assessed math ability for head
start kids
so more cowbell always more cowbell
also
the government accountability office
found several head start centers around
the country actively counseling families
to under-report their incomes in order
to appear eligible for the services so
they were facilitating fraud
among the 175 head start centers
inspected by the inspector general none
fully complied with federal head start
or state requirements to protect
children from unsafe materials and
equipment 21 of 24 grantees did not
fully comply with federal head start or
state requirements to conduct criminal
records checks conduct recurring
background checks document criminal
records checks conduct checks of child
care exclusion list or conduct checks of
child abuse and neglect registries
and we keep spending money on it so
they're like what if we do that okay so
back to the white house plan here so
you've got the little kid going through
the full-scale government program
all the way through
and it doesn't end there there's more
benefits cradle to grave they're not
hiding the ball it's all cradle to grave
stuff from this administration of course
because this is the goal the end goal is
to reorient how americans interact with
the government
this is joe biden's plan is anybody up
for this you wonder why glenn youngkin
is winning in virginia might have
something to do with this okay so back
to leo's story so here's what we know
about leo born to a single mom because
daddy is nowhere in the picture
he's been in government schooling since
he was three
when leo leaves high school he's able to
enroll in communica in a community
college thanks to extended pell grants
and investments in community college so
apparently leo is uh is is not one of
the bright eggs so he goes to the
community college and requires a pell
grant in order to do so and then this is
my favorite part of the whole
presentation thanks to community college
leo lends a good paying union job as a
wind turbine
technician oh will he
is that going to be a rich industry wind
turbine technician
honest to god i don't know how many how
many wind turbine technicians are there
how many people
work in the wind industry in the united
states
apparently there are currently
eighty-five thousand americans currently
employed in the wind power industry and
related fields
eighty-five thousand they're 330 million
people but apparently we're all gonna be
working at when at wind farms that's
what we're gonna be doing and a union
job right it's gonna be a union job
it's gonna be an expensive boondog so
he's gonna be working for the government
effectively because if you're working on
a wind turbine farm there's a very good
shot that is a government subsidized job
leo's job is one of four million new
jobs a year supported by president
biden's economic plan right so there it
is so joe biden is going to quote
unquote create jobs by subsidizing
give away goodies to union buddies and
leo's going to work for one of those
people later in life linda needs home
care and hearing care thanks to
president biden's plan linda can access
affordable hearing care through medicare
and leo is able to afford at home at
elder care for his mom
okay so that's again very exciting stuff
so the government is going to pay for
linda to get hearing care because
apparently no elderly people in the
united states have hearing care
that's a new one to me because my
grandmother does actually both
grandmothers do outside of medicare and
um and also apparently leo was going to
leave mom to rot but now that now that
he's got this subsidy to a union home
health care worker he's going to pay for
all that so again this is this is the
ideal life according to the democrats at
no point is there any upward trajectory
or upward mobility you basically just
stagnate in your lower middle class life
working as a wind turbine technician on
a government subsidy going to community
college
what an enriching and wonderful life
that sounds like is that that great what
an enriching wonderful exciting life for
the life of linda
again these are these are very humble
i would say these are pretty humble
aspirations for both leo and linda
they also don't have the slide where
where leo having been brought up in a
government facility all his life goes
out in the streets and starts burning
down government buildings because he's
very upset that the united states is
systemically racist and unjust
that part they didn't they didn't tell
you about because that part's a little
awkward
but right it was right before he went to
community college and also before he got
the wind turbine job leo
gotta love the fictional story see in in
the original american vision the
american dream was
linda works hard she works a job and she
works difficult and long hours but she
also takes care of her kid and she's
married so her husband is around to help
and they together invest enormous time
and effort in their son leo leo goes on
to create a new good product or service
and he then proceeds to start a business
where he hires lots of other people he
becomes inordinately wealthy having made
the country that much better off through
his own innovative skill and risk-taking
right that used to be the american dream
if you were to tell the horatio alger
story of the american dream that was the
american dream and that's true for so
many americans because the fact is the
vast majority of people who start at the
bottom of the american income spectrum
do not end up at the bottom of the
american income spectrum
people tend to rise over the course of
their life this is why older people are
richer than younger people in the united
states
but that's not the story the democrats
wish to tell they should tell you the
story about a lower income lower middle
income person middle income person who
stays a lower middle income person and
lives their life completely dependent on
government largesse
if that sounds like an inspiring life
story to you
i don't know what to tell you you should
be hoping for more you should be
aspiring for more
it's um
it it it is just amazing to me that this
is
what the biden administration seems to
want to push
this is the life that they seem to want
you to have
so
so wonderful so wonderful
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe